yeah sweet hell yeah tampa
tampa mark oh yeah baby it's wide open
people are moving here
uh i don't know man who knows what the
future holds but
people are are living for today and it's
uh
no one is scared down here it's wild oh
i i hope they're a little scared because
i don't want
old people to die but [ __ ] sure of
course but the
side splitters is their the capacity is
110 percent they're adding seats
what that's horrible
it's wild down here larry king came to
your show that's where that's where he
got it
larry king dr drew everybody i talked to
bert kreischer he said like
all these people are getting it now and
it's like it's just so weird it's like
it's locked down but people are still
getting it so you don't know what the
hell to do
yeah oh jesus yeah i i i have to address
the mustache as well
oh please we're all terrified i know
look
i i was in the shower i had a full beard
and i was like
i'm it's time it was getting itchy start
shaving
and runs out of battery i have like the
full i should have kept the full [ __ ]
thing i could have looked like tampa but
it was like all the way around
it was horrible and i had to trim away
but you know
you still i'm not i have very sensitive
weak skin i'm [ __ ] breaking out
i whittle it down to this but i [ __ ]
look like
it looks like freddie mercury you look
like super mario over here you got a
full stash and it's
dick dude one time to matteo lane uh
we did the roast battle thing and i said
you look like you have freddie mercury
poisoning
that's great but uh yeah dude it's uh
yeah it's nothing nothing go anytime
anything uncovered related
happens that's shitty i'm like this
isn't fair right
you know i know i know it's it's a
nightmare this whole thing's
annoying you heard they're they're
vaccinating um
uh grocery store employees now they
deserve it man
they do but those guys are getting laid
more than us
they're like on the front lines they're
working the first time grocery store
guys are getting laid
i saw a guy in a gristiti's head i was
like this guy's just he's just wearing
that for the [ __ ] i could tell
he's got the vaccine he's got a job he's
killing it so a fresh direct guy with
two models
you know this pussy's fresh direct
to my face grubhub indeed
oh you got like a you got like a reel to
go glass in the club
well i wanted uh i wanted a real cup and
they were out of to go cup so i got a
tito's and soda oh we gotta talk about
our drink
oh yeah burke christ is from tampa
uh i was i'm in tampa so i got tito's
and soda and honor
and uh it's a great just refreshing
night ending drink it really is it's
also like it's like a real housewives
drink but it's also it's like a weight
watching drink
but it's good it's so good it's so light
and it's bubbly
and the vodka is not bad i put a lime in
there it's all you need folks
i uh i did a similar thing i'm a little
embarrassed now that we're still on the
same page here but uh
i'll show the bottle first i did a
little i did a tequila soda
oh nice i did the rock stuff i got the
taramana
oh what's i don't know taramana it's
like it's like what clooney had with
casa amigos the rock has terra mana
a bottle is like 20 cheaper than cos
amigos casamigos is great but it's like
it's got a lot of play now so taramana
it's like 35 bucks for a bottle in new
york so i'm sure it's cheaper
wherever else but uh that's great good
mix that with a little uh
sell i do the spin drift i like this
stuff it's got a little i love that [ __ ]
yeah dude i got a little cranberry
raspberry actually nice [ __ ] nice
dude i do a lot of the sometimes i'll do
a little vodka with the uh
the lemon uh black tea one oh yeah
it's almost like an arnold palmer type
thing it's nice oh
man that's a great drink and i used to
love
i might be i'm older than you so did you
ever have clearly canadian
oh i love that [ __ ] oh man i used to
love that [ __ ]
it was like uh it was like it was like
sugary seltzer but it was
really good yeah it was a good good way
for a kid to like transition into
seltzer
you know it's like the elliott page of
something
but uh man i used to love that [ __ ] and
that was back when nobody was doing that
now they're everywhere
clearly canadian was like i'm gay and
then shelter is like i'm now a woman
that's how you exactly exactly
but that's a great it's a great mixer so
a good call there
krusty the clown mug too
that's pretty good sounded more like
mackie but
what'd you do for new year's uh i did a
gig in brooklyn i did shafi hussein
uh our buddy did a show uh outdoors it
was great
heated tents just worked out new [ __ ] uh
brought rachel feinstein with me we hung
out worked out new had a few
had a few tequila had a few bud light
mangoes
hey that's great has been the fireman
pete oh i love pete
it was fun it was a good time but new
york is killing me because
we've tried to get dinner after the show
it's like 9 30.
all right we're walking around brooklyn
see like uh like all these cool
restaurants you're like oh let's go one
of these places literally all of them
are like we can't take you anymore
i'm like it's [ __ ] new years dude i
know it's i i get that like
the early curfew but even i know it's a
pandemic i know like
look we're being very careful like but
the fact that this city closes down at
10 is like one of the most heartbreaking
things
never thought i'd see the day and also
coffee shops are closing
you you used to get like eight or
something for a coffee shop sometimes
it's like four now because they're like
yeah no one's buying coffee past four
right he's closing down you know so it's
it's killing me
and it's cold out that's the thing about
new york like you'd always go like all
right it's freezing but i'll get a cup
of coffee i'll sit inside and and write
or listen to whatever
podcast now you can't go inside it's
it's ruined so what do you do you got to
stay in your apartment
dude it was it was brutal we we were
walking around for a while
and we found uh you know we've got like
a pizza place and we're like can we just
like sit in your little heated area and
they were like no
we had to just like i said we were like
this is being homeless
yeah yeah exactly basically i mean we
had money and we
you know it's not homeless but you know
but it it's crazy what uh
what the city's become man it's just
it's i still love it i'm but
the late night thing kills me like the
two bodegas by me that used to be open
one used to be open all night
it's it's closed at like eight now oh
it kills me it's the worst man it's not
worth the money there it like i get it
they don't want to stay open
all night right with that money but it's
but damn
yeah i never thought i'd see the day
like i went down to new orleans for
thanksgiving and i was like well new
orleans they're a bunch of degenerates
animals that's going to be wide open and
they were shut down which
it's the right thing to do and all that
but i'm like i never thought i'd see
this
like bourbon street was pitch quiet you
could drop a pin
it was insane it's like the party animal
from high school and he shows up in like
a v-neck and a wife and he's sober
and you're like dude what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] happened to you
i know and you're you're like proud of
him in a way but you're also like
dude you're in finance what you married
a mormon
what it's crazy bourbon street wasn't
supposed to work with numbers man
bourbon street should be supposed to be
a [ __ ] up it's a it's a bummer yeah
exactly great way to put it charles new
orleans like the magazine street it's
like
those are like party streets those are
like where the action is so it's
completely you know bourbon bourbon's
the guy who doesn't wear a condom and
now he's like
selling trojans it's weird yeah
it doesn't doesn't add up but yes i get
it
it's crazy times yeah it's rough so
how was tampa side splitters new years i
mean it was great we we did uh we did a
couple shows and i did the countdown and
uh the girlfriend came on stage and like
gave me a glass of champagne at midnight
and then we did the arm
thing and drank it and uh you know you
try to stay safe you try to wear a mask
and all that but it was
it was mayhem and then there's drugs and
you know uh they
they lock the door that's it's you and
the staff and it's uh it's a
quite a brouhaha you just you just i
just picture you with a switchblade in
your mouth and a [ __ ] syringe
wrapping around
like you try to keep it you know cool
yeah i had a needle somebody's like what
are you doing i'm like it's the vaccine
don't worry
but yeah it was it was wilder the next
day you're hung i puked i haven't puked
since 88 yeah [ __ ] we went after it i
puked in the parking lot
of the hotel like on the i drove dry i
mean it was it was bad news luckily it's
like an eight-minute drive but that's a
that's a trash move man a parking lot
vomit
and there's nothing worse than you're
hungover you hate yourself you're
ashamed the next day
the sun is shining and you go out to get
in the car and you see the vomit
ooh yeah that's rough eye opener right
there
that's like seeing the blood after a
murder you're like [ __ ] i did that
that's horrible yeah exactly and then
you see the vomit you get in your car
then you go drink during the day and hit
the beach so yeah and then you have to
do
and was it hard to do the shows that
hung over well here's the thing i don't
know why they do this but there was no
friday show
so thursday was new year's you go nuts
and then we had friday off
so it was perfect having a girl down
here because like we hit the beach
we got there's no like oh it's almost
show time i gotta i gotta
go honey it was just all day all night
yeah it's it's the the hangover now like
i i'm having to like watch it a little
just because the hangover
pandemic hangovers are like next it's a
new level of depression
where i can't i'm like i'm like what am
i doing
i'm too old for this [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ]
loser i
yeah i'm panicking a little bit when i
get that anxiety that's like i [ __ ]
meditated the other day i don't meditate
i'm not a meditator yeah well you got to
do what you got to do by the way worst
worst james cameron film the meditator
holy [ __ ]
is that a real movie no no i'm not
a terminator joke but yeah that would be
horrible but yeah
i'm an idiot uh the the uh the hangovers
now
it's it's next level it used to be i'm
queasy i'm puking
i i'm mad at myself i have shame and now
it's like anxiety
on top of depression on top of
questioning your life choices
yeah it's the 30s man it's it's a whole
new level of hangover
yeah it's rough man i i i gotta i gotta
watch it a little bit i'm trying to
i'm trying to like get back in my back
my neck was out for like two
months so i'm like just getting back
into shape i'm just like
figuring out how to it's hard to get
into shape and a pandemic because
everything's [ __ ]
at everything like literally you know i
don't know
it'll it'll get
we're at the beginning here of like the
end i think beginning of the end i think
you're right and also you were a
basketball guy
you were a uh i've been playing outdoors
yeah well swimming is killing me that
was my thing
well swimming is so good for there's all
these health benefits and i was i was
hitting the gym twice a week
i don't want to be ripped i just like to
you were kind of ripped though
well it was like a mental thing it's
like this discipline and you're getting
in the zone and then if you if you break
the chain you feel horrible
you got to get back into it and i'm at
my house now like
let me lift this paint can for a minute
or let me hit this water jug like
you're just trying to find heavy [ __ ] oh
my girlfriend she's put on some weight
whatever it takes
it feels like lame rocky is what it
feels like you know
he's like going to town on a [ __ ] i'm
looking looking at a cornish hand i'm
like what can i do with this [ __ ] right
here i don't know
all right a game bird can i do anything
with that yeah no it's it's brutal it's
uh
it's hell and yeah i was doing like soup
cans i was doing like literally soup
cans on the floor like trying to just
figure some stuff out to like strengthen
my back it's embarrassing
yeah whatever it takes it is
embarrassing somebody should do a video
of that
like home workout like you got the the
crushed tomatoes you know you're going
over the head with a can or something
that could be fun it is yeah and it's
you know the thing is though it's like
that's a great point because all these
kettlebells and dumbbells
on amazon are sold out because everyone
[ __ ] was like i need weights
yeah by the way who's getting more of a
workout than the amazon guy he's got to
deliver those kettlebells so he doesn't
realize that he's lifting weights
literally on a delivery that sounds it's
like the hedberg joke he's a drug dealer
i don't even know what he's a
bodybuilder don't even know it
that's that [ __ ] hedberg joke damn ah
hedgebrook is too good man what do you
think of joe list's theory about hedberg
is the ultimate feature
[ __ ] that [ __ ] are you kidding me what's
the feature he's the best
he's the best deadpan one-liner guy ever
are you kidding me well i don't know
stephen wright
yeah they're both up there here's the
thing about the one-liner guys you
if you're gonna be a one-liner guy i'm
talking dimitri martin
i love demetrius yeah stephen wright
jeselnik you have your persona has to be
jessica i left jeselnik off he's great
obviously
he's great i mean you have to be a
persona
to be a one night you because it has to
make up for the fact that you're not
moving and you know acting out and the
jokes
every word has to be so
precise and meticulous like your whole
exactly has to be so figured out
uh yeah i mean hedberg has
some some albums where he's just [ __ ]
bombing these are albums yeah
totally totally also steven wright only
had that one album is my only thing
true he added a new one later the first
one is a it's one of the best albums
ever
that's amazing i went to a diner that
said breakfast anytime so i ordered
french toast during the renaissance
i mean incredible jeans i went to a
convenience store
uh it said 24 hours but they were closed
and he's like i thought you said 24
hours he's like yeah not in a row
she's they had some jokes on there that
like blue i didn't know you could write
jokes like that i
lost my socks i called information i
mean come on
like next level abstract [ __ ] it's a
small world but i wouldn't want to paint
it
who writes that and it's like that's a
joke stephen why is stephen wright not
on twitter he'd be
[ __ ] destroying twitter he's too good
for it he's too good for it yeah
that twitter would ruin him they'd be
like i'll give that a favorite [ __ ] you
that you're gonna get it emo phillips
great one-liner guy he's great on
twitter
great one-liner guy great on twitter and
another guy proving my point you gotta
have a big
persona if you're gonna be a one-liner
guy yeah one-liners are tough man
i was a one-liner guy when i started for
the most part and it's just like
i just was like i can't write hours like
this yeah you need a story every now and
then you need a chunk
you need a pov you know well not a lot
of very um personal one-liner guys cause
how would you be
good point good point personal is a big
one
where everybody's like you gotta be
personal you gotta talk about your life
and your family but carlin
not very personal never heard about his
daughter or his marriage or anything in
his book and his book he writes about it
but you're right
yeah last words he talks about it but
not in a stand-up
um brian kylie amazing one-liners
watch his letterman's jimmy carter
oh [ __ ] you're right there's some great
one lineup guys although i will say
you know who is kinda i mean we've
talked about him on the podcast before
but nick griffin has short jokes and is
very personal
oh good point good he's like probably as
close to
as what you get as like a one-liner guy
who's who's like kind of burying your
soul
you know yeah that's true he lets it all
out and pretty clean like he'll throw
a [ __ ] in every now and then or a [ __ ]
but it's
it's uh only when necessary he he could
do
he could do an hour clean easy and you
wouldn't notice
that's a good point yeah it's great when
it's when it's like it doesn't matter
when you're like watching a guy and
you're like i couldn't even tell that
was dirty or clean
i just yeah it was good bargatsi's got
that
he's just a good comic you're not like
he's a great clean comic he's just a
killer comic
yeah that's true yeah i remember i did a
show with someone once and i was
laughing so hard
i forgot what clean comic was before me
but i was laughing so hard and
the booker was like i didn't think you'd
like him and i was like
the [ __ ] are you talking about it's
comedy it's like i know
right i i like to laugh i like good
jokes
what is like i think people make an
assumption that you're only
gonna like people similar to you whereas
sometimes it's the opposite
usually it's the opposite yeah that's
what's great about norm is norm is
pretty clean
and he's like this brilliant guy like
that the dog walker the hobo with the
dog joke that's all clean
ah i think that was a classic classic
his last letterman was
killer with the germans fighting world
war ii
fighting the world all that was gold
what uh do you have any pet peeves this
week
oh geez uh here's the thing that
happened that i want to run this by you
yeah this i'm gonna sound like an
[ __ ] i'm gonna sound like a [ __ ]
but yeah they're boarding the planes
back to front now cause with covid
and i've never had more points and i
want to use them i want to get on first
but i brought him back to front so i
gotta wait you got a first class ticket
and you're you're waiting
yeah i mean you've if you were just some
like rich shitty guy
i'd be like [ __ ] you but you put in your
time to get those miles like you earned
them
yeah you're a road dog i get a little
annoying with status on flights because
like
we fly so much right like like i wanna
be in the delta club i wanna [ __ ] i
know
i wanna i wanna like hang out you know i
status
flying is like i want comfort if we're
gonna be flying this much and we
we ate [ __ ] for years doing the road we
flew frontier in spirit no offense
to those airlines but uh you know
they're the worst they're the worst
i mean how many times were you i was in
that back seat where you're like all
right [ __ ] it i made it finally back
here but
oh it doesn't recline because you hit
the bathroom totally so how many people
do you fall asleep
face first into this tiny yes i'm like
this is like this should be illegal
this should be [ __ ] this is like in
guantanamo this is how they sit
people why is my back so [ __ ] up my my
frame for one thing probably that i
never lifted weights to improve my back
but a third thing is all the travel
that's really what it comes down to
and yeah i i'm not gonna ever begrudge a
fellow comedian for
for complaining about travel conditions
ever i mean
yeah and look we're low maintenance
we're not we're not these diva guys but
like i finally got all these points and
these
miles put together after years of road
dogging at funny bones in cincinnati's
and you name it
and then we're now boarding back to
front and i'm like yeah
right when i get to this gold i can't
you but not for not for now
i mean not forever i mean it's it's it's
a good thing right
yeah it's a covet thing which and look i
get it it makes sex it actually makes
more sense but
joe listen a great point not to bring
him up again but he's like why don't
planes just it should be like a baseball
game when you show up you get your seat
it should be i hate this like boarding
zone ones
like look open the door let people come
and go as they please and then we'll
take off
that's not a bad point it's not bad
it's his point um yeah i don't hate it
i'm worthy you know why they do it
because these come
guzzling nazis with their capitalism
have to go
we can sell more because people want
zone one so we can get another 20 bucks
out of this guy
at the last minute oh they they take
[ __ ] away every year
i mean i've read some yeah statistic how
much they say by like
giving one less olive yes snack thing
where you're like
oh it like you think about they're like
well i guess it's a lot of money
when you think right right but also [ __ ]
you it's a [ __ ] olive
yeah and i mean they do the same with
the olives they do it with the inch like
i remember a seat used to be pretty big
now a seat's like
three or two inches smaller than it used
to be and just we're getting fatter and
the seats are getting smaller not just
fatter or bigger like look at look at
look who played basketball in like the
60s the center was like six foot three
now right now they're like seven five
and was like
why are the seats smaller we're bigger i
think like
sometimes when i see pro athletes and
i'm like what about the guys who missed
out what if like shaq
what if shaq wasn't a basketball player
and he was just like some dude that
worked at barnes and noble
and when he flew he's like i guess i got
a sick coach like are you [ __ ] yeah
that's a great point that's a girl he'd
have to buy two seats and it would ruin
his uh
income yeah you're right that's a great
point and it's [ __ ] up that
i'll tell you tall people and fat people
the clothes are the same price i think
which is interesting like a shirt for a
fat guy and a tall guy is the same as a
shirt for
a skinny guy and a short guy so that's
kind of nice it's big and tall
oh they have their own that's the store
big and tall are they are they more
money because it seems like more fabric
would
look real estate you're getting more
square foot
you're going to pay more in rent well
kids choose with fabric
kid's shoes the same shoes are less
expensive so i would assume that if it
was more yeah it would probably cost
more
also if it's more custom-made and rare
which
like true you have a size 20 size foot
yeah i'm gonna assume you got to pay
more for it
i don't know that for a fact but that's
kind of unfair that you're just born
that way
you didn't do anything and now you're
[ __ ]
that's a good point that's kind of
unfair it's it's
i mean you're a minority in a way you're
tall by the way
giants giants are a minority giants are
minority
and so we're little people yeah yeah
they're really minor
but they get i feel like little people
can have
they have more options like a little guy
on a plane
wouldn't you rather wouldn't you rather
be a giant though i would rather be a
giant good point good point
at least the giant gets laid i think but
a little person on a flight
is first class no matter what seat he's
in
that's true it's all leg room yeah but
you're now you're just breaking down
the little person to just flying ah
that's the problem right what about in
the grocery store when he needs a giant
to grab him from the top shelf
good point you're a little person you
can only drink bottom shelf liquor
[Laughter]
well the i guess the point is in life
there's perks to everything
and flaws to everything true yeah
i think i'll still take the giant
because in my mind i'm like giant
i can make the nba i just got to get a
free throw down i'm in
right it's more than that that's not
true but yeah i just think a giant you
have a better
yeah all around yeah yeah it is funny
how like
certain things are status like i see a
giant dog in new york and i'm like
in this [ __ ] city you know i don't
get that well
they must have a decent place
or right that's what i'm saying it's a
status symbol a small
little dogs people are like everywhere
in new york i'm like no it's just we
have smaller apartments in new york
right right it's almost like how fat in
the renaissance was a sign of wealth
because you could afford all that food
that you're so overweight
and that's the same with dogs now you
can afford the space
that's a good point interesting yeah
it's funny how how
fat used to be although fat is still
powerful sometimes
like tony soprano you're like that's
powerful good point
good point if you're like so fat and
it's and you're also successful you're
like well that person just doesn't care
and they're fat and that's kind of
ultimate power
yeah not caring is the ultimate power
going back to our my road bit that you
you helped me with it's all about power
but yeah you're right but you're gonna
have more health issues but you're just
like yeah
i'm that rich i'm that comfortable i i
could
i can make it work yeah
that's a that's a good pet peeve let me
go oh you gotta i wanna hear your pet
peeve
you go you go first or whatever you're
gonna say well i was gonna say back to
the
tequila thing yeah i've been sitting on
this
you mentioned clooney you mentioned the
rock did you hear clooney made so much
money
that he gave 10 of his friends a million
dollars each
i heard it was 14. oh is it 14. i could
be wrong but i thought it was 14. yeah
wow that what a guy
if you got the money like you know why
not right
like yeah he i think he made 500 mills
so i hope it wasn't like everyone in
ocean's 11 and then like three other
friends
wasn't like just all his rich friends
yeah matt damon doesn't need it
maybe the little asian guy might but
jesus but i heard he gave it to like
high school friends and college friends
can you imagine
like [ __ ] oprah's look under your seat
he just blew her out of the water
yes you're right he gave him all
suitcases like out of the movies where
they flip it up
and they flop open and it's uh just cash
it'd be so great if they got tailed and
someone
robbed them now that's an ocean's 11.
he's like who's doing it ironically it's
andy garcia that's who got you back
stole the money back right right yeah
that's a whole another movie
but what a cool dude yeah what a [ __ ]
dude
clooney is uh a clue i just watched an
interview with him and he uh
he's talking about out of sight which i
think is a great movie from the 90s
soderbergh i think soderbergh and he's
talking about how he and soderbergh
could not make a hit like they both were
like dying to make a hit
and people were saying like clooney's
not a movie star which like it's
hilarious if you look at him like the
dude's cary grant he's a movie
yes he's like as movie star but he's
also just like
got it like how do you not see that he's
even on er you're like yeah this dude
[ __ ] rules like
yeah great actor and good looking but
they were
they were uh he was saying like
soderbergh and him could not get [ __ ]
and no one wanted to work with either of
them and then they kind of just
teamed up and it's like well look what
happened they [ __ ] out of sight
also i don't think did that well at the
box office but it got so much critical
success that it like it didn't matter
people were like oh it's a great movie
great movie cheedle is the killer albert
brooks halo
brooks ving rhames i mean come on it was
just it was such a cool style
yeah steve zahn's underrated by the way
so underrated great act
saving silverman that thing you do great
comedic actor
he's he's great um yeah that movie ruled
i love that movie i love movies like
that where they actually give a [ __ ]
i know the box office doesn't care but
any kind of movie like that where it's
that
it's very artistic looking and that you
tell the director has a vision
and the dialogue kicks ass like the
opening scene the opening scene
where you should just youtube this if
you haven't seen it clooney robs a bank
and the way he does it
is so [ __ ] evil and with a smile it's
so like not how you think of him
where he just is he's just telling this
poor little bank clerk he's like
if you don't if you don't put the money
away i'm gonna shoot your friend in the
head over there that's my friend talking
to your friend and of course he doesn't
even know the guy
that's not his he's this is just a
shtick but by the way schtick was a
jewish way to talk about a bank robbery
in history
that's his schnick that's his little
routine no he uh
but the way he delivers this is like it
was badass
it was like a cool cool scene super cool
and
uh oh [ __ ] i forgot i was gonna say
oh so cool i read this article about
clooney because you want to hate the guy
not hate him but you want to be like all
right let me find a flaw in this guy
he's too handsome he's too suave
yeah but he's obsessed with directing he
wanted to direct
so he got into hollywood just so he
could direct which i think is so cool
like
he said i'll do facts of life i'll be
the handyman
literally the handyman on facts of life
which is just some rinky dink sitcom
and he just worked his way up slowly and
then he directed goodnight and good luck
and it was like a great movie
yeah that's all he wanted to do well
before that i think he directed
confessions of a dangerous mind oh yeah
that's right also a really cool movie i
mean
he's great i love the guy yeah and uh
sam rockwell is another killer that no
one talks about
ah he's doing fine people talk about him
all right i hope
he's he's doing great he's doing well
he's in a lot of [ __ ]
i hope so i worry about these guys he's
like griffin to me where i'm like do
people know about this guy
he's doing great
i just don't think he's not the right
guy he's in [ __ ] he probably works
more than he can
and then he can fill his schedule his
agents probably like dude you're good
i hope so i hope so sam rockwell really
i don't know i mean he's not only he's
not like uh he should be on tmz
or front page news a variety you know
moon is killer first off if you're on
tmz these days you're either cheated or
you're
or you're dead so you don't want to be
on tmz
he was in charlie's angels as the
villain like 20 years ago
that was like he's working he's been
working okay forever
at martin mcdonough movie with francis
mcdormand he's he's working everywhere
oh that's right three billboards or
whatever yeah he's an
all right all right thank god i turned
into my aunt there i'm like i've never
heard of him in anything and i'm like
he's in 18 movies
here dude moon he's in like go to his
imdb and you're like this dude's in
every movie
that's true you're right seven
psychopaths he was in
recently yes he's just that good he just
like slips into a roll
no he's [ __ ] awesome but he's doing
fine he's not
i'm not worried about him all right if
they're under the top of the forbes list
i'm like oh this guy's struggling he's
probably homeless i'm worried about it
no he's all right but it just feels like
if you've got a liquor now
it used to be like in the 90s michael
jordan opened a
steak house holy [ __ ] he's made it and
now you gotta have a liquor
oh jordan had everything jordan had a
cologne
it's like true it smelled like dog [ __ ]
he like jordan just like just
that was like the 90s i feel like just
put your name on [ __ ] anything
yeah well the sneakers were such a hit
that i think he was like what else
let's keep going sneakers are like the
all-time biggest
i mean because he was with nike when
nike was [ __ ] you saw that in the dock
right
yeah that's right that's right isn't
that crazy to think nike was like
a middle-of-the-road shoe company yeah
that's insane it's insane because it's
literally now like
yeah zion got into uh no no wasn't no
it was steph curry under under under
armour yeah he got a fat deal because
but that's the way to do it everyone
makes fun of him because his his
sneakers do look like
geriatric nurse [ __ ] i mean they don't
look great but
that's how you do it man mm-hmm i think
yeah the 90s were like throw your name i
was thinking about this
because remember bill hicks had that
famous bit about how leno's a sellout
because he did doritos commercials
yeah and literally now if bill hicks
were a comic he'd have a podcast where
he'd be like
all right [ __ ] the world [ __ ] trump [ __ ]
everyone [ __ ] biden
adam and eve adam and eve.com
all your dildos and sex he would do
[ __ ] anything nowadays you're right
you're right that's so true i guess he
shout on leno cause lena was like
at the he was on the the tonight show
already he's like how much do you need
but i still think about that where it's
like [ __ ] it man who gives a [ __ ] at
this point
i know once i saw david cross do alvin
and the chipmunks i was like
all right this is the like ultius kind
of like uh
on the fringes guy ever and he's doing
chipmunks like come on the guys morgan
you know david cross gave
[ __ ] to every comic in the 90s who did i
know like that and now he's doing alvin
and the [ __ ] chipmunks come on man
exactly they all they all fall through
because you got to pay the bills and you
want a boat or you want a house in the
catalina whatever it is so i get it yeah
who's the joke on really like oh [ __ ]
you sell out you're like i'm
doing i'm hocking doritos so i can have
a helicopter
yeah it's [ __ ] uh it's [ __ ] dumb
i don't i don't get it but uh i also
think like now i see
kevin hart on tv so much where i'm like
i'm watching the knicks game the other
night and his ad
played literally every break to the
point like i gotta mute the tv because
it's making me
[ __ ] insane and they're like he's
getting paid every time that comes on
i know and i'm literally like he's
getting paid so much that i'm like i
can't hear anymore
stop it yeah he's the guy where i'm like
i get it you're five one you're hustling
but like
take a breather man like i like to work
that's why he's that big
dude i guess so cuz he was i remember i
was like
i remember i was on uh what's that show
in indianapolis where they [ __ ] hated
me
uh crackers yeah but what's the morning
show they do this oh bob and tom
oh man so i'm vomiting on that [ __ ] and
uh and he called in to promote
a new uh to promote a new movie it's
like he's like he's that's how he's
wired he'll call
the local indianapolis show
oh my god that's how you that's how you
get that successful you're like
you know yeah i heard a story about him
uh back when he was like a young comic
in philly like just starting to headline
he would stand outside after his show
he'd kill then he'd stand outside after
a show with like a
marble composition book and go hey if
you like the show write your email down
and i'll email you next time i'm in town
and so you know
100 people would write their email down
and
literally he would put it in you know by
hand
one by one and then next year he would
hit him up again and they would come
back out and he would sell out
everywhere
i tried to do that after i heard him say
that on marin i think and i tried to do
that
and uh i got i got bored
one by one was a lot and also like it's
a [ __ ] insane
you start trying to look at at people's
handwriting like is it a three or an
eight
right right no i've seen people do with
like the ipad but now it's like just
[ __ ] follow me on social media man
don't make me like i i have to do we
have to do so much [ __ ]
that that the people that came before us
didn't have to do
like jerry seinfeld didn't have to cut
up clips
and get them captioned and be like like
find you like the amount of content that
we have to put out to stay relevant now
like i don't want to hear it from our
[ __ ] elders dude i don't
i get it man i mean and i love the guys
i respect them but like i don't want to
hear it
you were able to tour with the same
[ __ ] hour
i know you do one tonight show or one
whatever leno letterman and you were in
like letterman
not one i shouldn't say that but like
that was that was the social media it
was tv that was it
you do an evening evening at the moment
they were gatekeepers but still like
dude i feel like we have to do like the
amount of carson's it used to take to be
a star we have to do like specials now
oh that's good that's a good way to put
it
i think you're right like bill burr said
it best he's like a special is now just
an advertisement for the road like here
if you like some of this
come see me on the road where the
special used to be a special this
it was almost like a movie like here we
go this is it you get popcorn you'd call
your friends you put on hbo and you
watched it
now it's like here's an ad for my road
[ __ ]
come see me on the road that's a good
point i thought of a carson bit that
this one this would never work with
anyone but a comic but like you ever
going down on your girlfriend
and she's coming and she gives you the
little motion up to come up and [ __ ]
yeah that's like the equivalent of the
carson like you made it to the couch
yeah yeah right that's like that'll
never make a that'll never make a
anyone but a comic even smile like
that's my one
yeah see i never got to the couch when i
eat a girl out i just get this
[Laughter]
yeah perfect which is what he used to do
when he didn't get to the couch but yeah
totally
oh i got it i loved it yeah only a comic
would get that so
what's your pet peeve we went off on a
whole another tank i got a few i'm
trying to think which one to do it with
here's i think this might be mine so
all right i'll try this one meditation
is is
i all right i'm trying it it's very hard
i know you're not into it
i tried it i really gave it a real shot
like 10 tries and i can't do it you're
too restless i think
that's my yeah that's my guess here's my
thing i tried
i even called you know i talked i text
didn't listen him but i we were texting
for a while about it and i was like
tell me what to do he's in a tcm i'm i'm
very base
level beginner and
turner classic movie what is that yeah i
know yes it's a humphrey bogart
meditation it's when
i do edward g robinson you go she that's
how you meditate
that's my mantra see right right
well what is tcm tcm is transcendental
um oh okay okay okay so i uh i'm doing
very base level [ __ ] i'm doing like
headspace the app
i just started and uh look it drives me
insane some of the like i'm there
because i have bad depression i'm trying
to deal with and
you know you have this crippling
depression and and the guys are like
this is for depression
uh notice everything in your room and
i'm like okay
and he's like notice the smells i'm with
the smells i'm here because i'm [ __ ]
miserable you want me to
like i'm gonna be like what is that uh
take out chinese i'm cured thank you
all right hey right yes yes my leftover
is great it drives me insane
so yeah uh that's one yeah that's one
that's driving me crazy the whole like
notice everything in your body it's a
pandemic dude i can't i haven't been
exercising i
like it's like literally everything
that's like triggering my [ __ ] mental
illness already
yeah i'm with you i mean they go listen
to do you hear the fan
focus on the fan you're like i hear the
fan but i also hear the hobo and
in the street yelling and he's talking
about you know the aliens and the jews
this is not helping notice all the
sounds what is it a black israelite what
the [ __ ] was that
is he in the hallway how did he get here
right right now exactly
new york maybe it's not the best place
to meditate you hear sirens and [ __ ]
yes gun shot but then you have that
moment where you're like well maybe
they're worse off than me and that maybe
gives you a little boost but it
you know it's uh that's not bad it's
it's a lot right now i'm gonna stick
with it as long as i can but uh try it i
guess but yeah it's
there there are a lot of them there's
some for creativity i just wanna like i
think the focusing on the breathing i
get that i can get down
that's good but it might be a bit maybe
you have this bit but it
it just seems weird that you have a app
for meditation
the phone is the whole struggle with
frustration
and addiction is that yours no it's not
mine
oh okay but yeah like it's just weird
that i'm going to the phone again
to escape but i'm back on the phone
it just feels counter point like
literally everything is in the phone the
the dating apps the yes the email porn
porn everything everything negativity
whatever
just pictures pictures with my mom
it's all there yeah good point
yeah so meditation i think would be my
pet peeve but i'll stick with it i'll
stick with it and uh
they say it takes practice i'll report
back what about iraq you any good
recommendations
oh baby well this is gonna be a weird
one
hit me i love it i'm i'm going outside
the box here we usually do movies music
documentary whatever it is
and it's anything it's what we it's what
we make it
all right so we where it's a drink it's
one more drink it's a boozy show
i gotta recommend and i wish i had one
on me
there's a you know there's white claw
there's bud light
whatever seltzer there's all these uh
weird ones but high noon
i drank it all christmas it's a great
it's it's not a seltzer beer whatever
you call it it's a
actual vodka and seltzer drink it's not
like a malt liquor
it's actually liquor and you go and you
get it like the
at the corner store they have it yeah
it's the same shape it's like the skinny
can
but it's a great great substitute where
you actually are drinking a cocktail
in a can instead of just drinking malt
liquor which is
white claw they're really uh whittling
their way into the
into the corner store because i feel
like the some of those corner stores
weren't allowed to sell the hard liquor
they were only
yeah the beer and now they're kind of
finding ways in they're right
right it's a good way in and like a lot
of people think these white claws are
like healthy for you it's just corn
syrup and other [ __ ]
and chemicals it's still bad for you
it's just better than beer fat wise
well it's less calories right yeah less
calories but this one is actually a
liquor and a seltzer in a can
and i can't recommend it enough and the
hangover wasn't so i don't think that's
healthy
[Laughter]
well i'm not i'm not saying you know
someone's actually a hard liquor
all right i think probably there's no
chemicals though it's just
uh liquor and seltzer and we're moving
on with our life
in a can it's not like it's not trying
to trick you yeah i don't think anyone
with the white club people i i hear you
i don't think any of them are health
junkies i don't think any of them were
like wait a minute
you know i think girls like them like
women like them because they're
local they're good they're drinking five
tonight
they're [ __ ] great they have them at
the club oh yeah i mean all the clubs
love them yeah a beach all that [ __ ] now
white clothes
damn good you know what's good when like
every other brand is fat you and your
[ __ ] i see corona
i see yeah but light they're all
stealing it yeah they're all stealing
but
high noon's a little different and they
taste great and
i had like 10 of them the hangover's not
that bad
it's it's a little more pure it's still
[ __ ] it's all in a can but it's
it's liquor and not malt liquor with
with flavors
huh that's interesting that's my all
right i'll i'll give it a go yeah i mean
i like to
go i like making my own [ __ ] but you
know also it's a good idea sometimes
when you want to go to the you want to
you want
a drink on the walk or something it's
kind of yes especially pandemic
man it's getting cold but i'll tell you
these new york shows
it's crazy we're still we're still
keeping them going they got the heat
lamps on people i like the outdoor vibe
still it's kind of still feels guerrilla
style still kind of exciting to me
so totally i'm sticking with that i did
that phantom power
i know it's not in new york but that
phantom power jerk and pa on your
recommendation
and it was like people out there with
blankets there's barrel fires as
heat lamps and they were great
it's great man i i the outdoor thing is
like i mean i think after this pandemic
i'm done with it forever so i'm trying
to be like let's really enjoy it
i don't think i'm gonna be hitting
people up for the rooftops once the
comedy cellar is open but uh
no we did our time do you think that
i think one good thing about the
pandemic and i hate it i'm ready to get
out it's a it's a [ __ ]
but we're gonna appreciate the [ __ ] out
of everything every diner hang
every restaurant every bar night every
flight every ev everything it's just
gonna be special
again i agree yeah i saw this buddhist
saying
i i'm gonna i'm paraphrasing it but it's
something about uh
to have extreme joy you must have
extreme pain as well and i'm kind of
like i didn't need this much joy dude
i would have been happy at like a three
or four i
know i didn't need you know it's not
like we didn't enjoy these diner hangs
to begin with we loved every minute of
them but oh dude i feel like how many
times we text each other like we have
such good lives we we were like we did
not
we were grateful i feel like that's a
good point
we had gratitude we'll be even more
grateful but i mean how often do we like
text each other like we just hung with
one of our heroes like we [ __ ]
we paid attention yeah we were present
that's true well we had such normal life
we were we're very normal
that's what i love about comedy now i'm
getting drunk and i'm i'm sorry i love
his here
but i'll go one more why not i'm a
little there you go
one more drink this actually feels like
hanging out now it really feels
i love it this was a tall glass here and
i'm at at the bottom and i had a bunch
of white claws but
this is what's great about comedy and i
know it's been said before but mick
jagger
is never going to see some bar guitar
player at a bar and go we should hang
out
and yet we've hung out with david tell
and seinfeld and
bill burr and all these [ __ ] legends
because comedy is so
much less pretentious than everything
else and
we're normal guys like you meet these
actors they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] they're the worst you're like
you're not even living on earth you're
so out
out to lunch these actors and you're
right they're still like
there's still a connection to like to
bar
life and still like yes somehow bar life
is is very egalitarian
you're all the bar together there's
something that's very every man about
bars that's kind of what i love about
him it's called a pub it's public that's
the whole thing
public and there's something about once
you become too famous we always say you
don't you're not funny anymore
usually there's there's a few exceptions
but like when you're true famous a lot
of time you're not funny because you
don't have a connection to reality and
uh you know
a lot of actors are weighted hand on
hand and you're just not
a person anymore you don't i mean i'm
not saying of course these actors like
work for their [ __ ] so many of them work
for
sure i mean that's a type of rejection
that's i think to me more painful than
what we do it's a good point
the waiting around uh and all that [ __ ]
yeah but like we at least can make our
own opportunities we're like [ __ ] a
pandemic we'll start our own show
you know right right there is something
cool about that whereas actors who kind
of have to wait
on a show like i i watched a thing and
it was cool but it's just so weird like
it was
christine baranski uh meryl streep and
audrey mcdonald they sang a song
from company the the uh stephen sondheim
show
and it was on [ __ ] zoom oh really
and it was cool they were all they were
all incredible i was like [ __ ] i didn't
know meryl streep could sing you're like
[ __ ] a man
but they all had amazing voices and it
was a cool production
and uh that is cool but it's on zoom but
they're still doing someone else's words
like we can still kind of make
you know like and that is kind of cool
so uh
and and there is something there is
something about
accessible comics are that it's good and
it's bad like i'm sure
yes every once in a while i go a little
crazy i'm like
but then i'm also like i do like that i
know who's coming up i do like that
right that guys ahead of us know
about us it's like there is something
and i'm sure it's all the same
in different art forms different mediums
or whatever but uh
there is something in comedy where like
they really
a lot of the legends are pretty cool yes
yeah the funny ones are usually cool
uh it's funny how the the mean ones are
always like i always thought you were a
hack anyway
but isn't it amazing how they're like
shitty to you on the way up and you're
just like
i'm gonna pass you dude like you're
[ __ ] crash
it's weird it's weird i remember someone
did that to me at the strip once
at the comic shop i was auditioning and
they did like an american idol style
thing and they just like trashed the
auditioning comics it was a hell gig i
had to wait
for [ __ ] ever you know and that yeah
it's auditioned me so many times this
trip it's crazy these clubs want you to
be so [ __ ] loyal
i know you're so badly on the way up and
i still have love for this trip because
i'm like who cares it's all sure
i still love it but like some of the
[ __ ] they put you through and then
you're getting critiqued by like a
[ __ ] like a a restaurant host
basically like who are you you're not
going to be around man
i know so so then
uh one of the so they had comics signed
up which i'm like in my head like what
comics in their [ __ ] right mind or
signing up to critique other comics like
it's so uncommon like what right so
uh anyway uh
i remember a comic i didn't respect was
like yeah a little hacky and i was like
you're the [ __ ] i want to be like
you're the biggest [ __ ] hack i've
ever seen
of course and uh yeah
and another guy was like i mean and then
i remember auditioning the week later in
two comics i respected judge and they
gave me they gave me love and it's like
you know it's so [ __ ] dumb
there you go the people that are shitty
to young comics on the way up it's like
it's crazy that's on you that's in your
in your
[ __ ] toxic world
you're insecure sorry you're pro it's
projection they're all projecting you
know like
i have some doubts i have some thoughts
so i'm gonna put that [ __ ] on you
it's all [ __ ] up it makes me sick and
you see these celebrities now like
wonder woman or whoever the [ __ ] is
doing these like black and white
yeah she's doing these black and white
things all these actors imagine
yeah and you're like oh that was rough
that's
and i get it there they have good
intentions and maybe they're donating
and all that
but they're out of touch that's right
they're out of touch
i don't know her i don't know i mean
like you know like i know she's also
done a lot of good like i'm sure she's
inspired a ton of little girls
with there aren't many female super the
funny thing is i don't even see wonder
woman but
from what i saw like there's so few
female superhero movies i saw birds of
prey i thought that was a good movie
but that movie [ __ ] that's like an
edgy female superhero movie and it
[ __ ] bombed
ah interesting i think it bombed because
it looked a lot like suicide squad and i
think that was horrible but it was
actually a good movie
but uh yeah with gal gadot it's like
it's just that i'm famous i'm surrounded
by people like she's gorgeous
she's surrounded by people who are just
like let me do this let me let me
dab your head here let me uh let me do
your hair yes
make sure nothing is wrong at any time
maybe you need a pimple sometimes yeah
that sinks in
but and look my point is i'm not i don't
i don't know why we got off on her i'm
not trying to
single her out but like i'm just saying
the out of touchness
is comics our whole job is to attack
that and not be that and and
[ __ ] and joke about people who do do
that and that's what i love
about this business you can have good
comics call out [ __ ]
yeah we call up [ __ ] we make fun of
that it's all it's it's policing
kind of pretension and some comics let's
be honest they
they get they get wrapped up in the same
way they are caught up in it yeah
well yeah absolutely but that you said
it very well policing pretension
and uh there's something about it like
the idea that like i'm sure people are
talking about to death but the idea that
you singing imagine like
the country's bleeding money people are
out of work small businesses are
crumbling
i know obsession people are impressed
out of the mind she's like
what if i sang a song i know you know
it's like
there's something tone-deaf about that
so right it's like it's a lack of
awareness but then also
like it feels arrogant and yes
it is a bummer when you see comics pop
up in that [ __ ] because you're like ah
you're better than that and you know
better than that completely completely
maybe you're not who the [ __ ] knows yeah
maybe you're not and
it tends to be the funny ones the
funniest
comics are the ones who are kind of void
of that like
no matter how much you do to them you
praise them you shower them with
compliments and money and fame
they it's still in there there's that
like how many times you put on a leather
jacket and you hear every
voice in your head going yeah you look
great but what are you kidding
you can't pull this off you're not gonna
go out you're gonna go outside with this
thing your footy fonzie get the [ __ ] out
of here we'll give you a pass
during a special but other than that go
[ __ ] yourself
don't fight yourself it is there's
something about comics
uh that we're like almost supposed to be
the the kids that didn't get into the
party i think
yes oh completely we're like we're like
they're like we're like on the outside
like i know a guy just let us in they're
just like sorry you're not
yeah i remember quinn once said
we're supposed to be the losers yes
that's why we're funny and it's like
i don't know we have to be like [ __ ]
losers but we don't but we shouldn't be
the
the winners of the winners and that is
like yes that keeps
when you're winning what's funny unless
unless you're like
delusional unless you're like like danny
mcbride winning or something right
yeah that's funny or rodney dangerfield
winning where it's like
that it works if you're like in back to
school or some [ __ ] but like yeah
yeah it usually it is a hard pull-off
it's also rodney looks the way he does
yeah that that all factors in i remember
uh jewel
julie louis drivers had a great point
about kramer she's like
he thinks he's the funniest guy in the
room and he's like
this unemployed hipster doofus with high
hair and a shirt from the 40s
that's why he's funny he thinks he's the
guy but he's not the guy and we all know
he's not the guy but he thinks it's like
tom mccaffrey
he's cocky and he's a he's a [ __ ]
job schmoe from new york and he thinks
he's this hot [ __ ] and that's [ __ ]
gold
those who don't know tom mccaffrey great
joke writer
really talks like new york guy but he
talks like a valley girl for some reason
he'll be like i'm awesome right i'm so
good at comedy that's how he would talk
he would do jokes like i just uh i just
read jenna jameson's autobiography
the movie was better
[Laughter]
jokes like that he was great i mean such
a funny dude
such a funny dude such a great joke
writer plus he had the persona
that's why like you know people always
say oh good-looking comics they don't
work they don't work and you're like
they do work if you're smart enough to
know about like daniel tosh is a
good-looking guy
but he's like i'm gonna go in on that
yeah and that's why he's clever that's
why he just made it you brought up julia
louie driver she's gorgeous i mean like
gorgeous she's still beautiful
i mean yeah i mean age funny's funny man
i
that's the other thing but she is
playing like
even on veep she's playing a [ __ ]
mess like she has
succeeded to that it's funny it's also
just inherently funny
when that you were the veep that you you
send it to the highest level
oh wait no you did great point you're
right here
so yeah i think what she's so good at
just like
still being self-deprecating and still
being i mean she
she's incredible i love i love julie
louie dreyfuss i was on colbert with her
once and i was so bummed i didn't get to
meet her
what so bummed no she's a bee that was
like i'm
it's rare that i'm like i need to meet
you yes
just a hello oh god that kills me
we didn't cross paths wow so many hours
of my life have been watching her
and just been in awe you know i
mentioned the bisque i mean i know all i
know everything i watched
seinfeld that's and she was on snl for
like 10 minutes
legend legend whatever
like are they vidal sassoon ah
i don't know about that somebody google
that give that a goog i don't know about
it we don't have anyone here
i thought he was like a like an oil guy
or a ship magnate
some something like that she's great uh
she's great hot and rich and still funny
i love her uh my wreck i've been telling
you about this i don't know if you got
on it yet
rick and morty i gotta get on this
okay let me tell you something first off
please the show is great
i think the fans push people away the
fans are annoying
[Laughter]
this is a real catholic church of a show
here
and uh no it's fantastic man it's like
it's so out there you know what i love
about it it's basically quick rundown
it's just like
a grandfather who's the smartest guy
he's the smartest guy in the world he's
a genius scientist
he's created portals that can go
anywhere other dimensions
he's also funny as [ __ ] he's quick with
a one-liner
and he takes his grandson on all these
adventures
and it just so many great plots and the
idea that
i think there's something about like all
the chaos and disorder in the world
right now
the fact that this guy's in complete
control of all of it and no one can beat
him because he's this omnipotent
type of being is providing a lot of
comfort right now for me
interesting and it's really
dan harmon created it who's [ __ ]
brilliant the guy is
so so [ __ ] funny yeah
highly recommend highlighting a great
premise just just hearing the primitive
because i've i've watched one or two and
i was like
it's okay and i don't know if i get it
what am i missing
because i was like the jokes aren't
amazing but i think when you're like oh
it's a grandfather
delivering a joke
i think i was missing something oh uh
yeah i was i was walking with ryan
hamilton our buddy the other day
and uh ryan goes ryan loves the show too
and ryan goes yeah the grandpa almost is
like a tell to me where he's like this
kind of wisecracking guy that keeps
winning like when you picture and tell
on stage you like he
he never loses in even the slightest you
know
joke misfires he saves it and that's
kind of like what the grandpa does he's
like
this genius but he's he farts and he
burps
there's like no you talked about no
pretension like that's what that
show has for me where he he has the
wittiest lines but then he'll like
fart and you're like it's so rare a guy
just burps while he talks
it's [ __ ] interesting it takes your
second like is he burping and you're
like oh they just
have a guy who burps so right okay all
right all right
i'm in i'm gonna do it on it
is that there's a pilot though is it on
youtube or where is it
hbo max okay okay i have that all right
i'm gonna do it i'm going on
the best streamer right now all right
i'm in
oh and i watched seoul on your
recommendation what'd you think give me
the honest
very very good i really liked it pretty
good
it's i saw nikki glazer tweeted
seoul was okay which made me laugh
because it's like literally every person
i see is like it's the greatest movie
i've ever seen
right i know i love it it's the greatest
but yeah it's a
for a kid's movie it's pretty damn deep
and i'll tell you this it doesn't feel
like a kid's movie to me
no no that's like what [ __ ] what
[ __ ] kid is into this movie
it's like about death and it's like your
life souls
all that metaphysics yeah it's great
that's my critique it didn't feel like a
kid's movie
i i i watched someone no no i enjoyed
the movie i'm just saying
i watch this movie about death and
purgatory and
accepting that your life is over and
giving up on your dreams it felt very
much like where we're at right now
yes i watch i watch it with ryan
hamilton again and and ryan even
commented as he runs down the steps to
go into the jazz club he's like
that may as well been the comedy seller
exactly so
the fact that he has to like give up on
his dreams and it's like
you have all those moments where you're
like this will be the time that i
figure it all out and uh it felt very it
felt very
relevant especially now somebody at a
great point i was talking to him about
seoul and they were like
it kind of just completely negates
religion
you know it's just like there's an
afterlife or there's a
there's no like heaven or hell it's just
like we're souls this is how it works
and i was like oh [ __ ] you're right
never thought about it that way
interesting yeah that's weird for some
kids i'm sure
yeah i just it didn't feel like a kid's
movie like i get how like even up is a
kid's movie even with that
[ __ ] depressing opening uh oh yeah
but
but then you think about it like all
those movies have some weird
parental [ __ ] or like like bambi even
going back or like
lion king they all have something yeah i
guess this is how you
how you introduce a kid to all this
stuff
let me ask you a slightly offensive
question
well i have you we're talking about kids
movies somebody told me fievel goes west
is a jewish kids movie
never heard of it what five bible
the mouse i don't know it wow okay maybe
not then if you don't know it as a
jewish fellow
i'm not the spokesperson i know but you
you grew up in that era
uh i never heard of this fievel goes
west wow
okay i might have seen it when it came
out but i was five when this came out so
i don't
i figured that was right up your anal
fiber goes west what was your go-to
movie as a kid what was your favorite
kid's movie i loved aladdin
huge aladdin fan i liked him i liked
that you know robert williams is in it
it felt like actually a funny movie for
kids gilbert godfrey
yes gilbert robin it was great it was a
great combo so there's comics in it so i
always loved aladdin
but uh let's see go too i mean i grew up
fast with i watched animal house when i
was like
five you know what i was way too young
my parents had a
you don't even get it though at five
you're like what am i watching right
i just love the fact that these guys
were living life and going crazy and all
that
uh it says so much about you that you
watch animal house at five
caddy shack all that [ __ ] i loved bill
murray he was my hero what about bob was
bill murray was my guy
that's interesting like i i rewatched
groundhog day and i was just like man i
loved him so much
like i still love him yeah yeah yeah he
was just like cool
we talk about like it's funny how we
just shat on comics for being cool
because i do think bill murray had like
a cool vibe it was always like very like
okay like it was always yeah it was
always like he'd always say like go [ __ ]
yourself without saying go [ __ ] yourself
yes yes he was kind of a [ __ ] but you
loved him but he was an every man but he
was
smarter than everybody but he was also
depressed i mean he had so many layers
and he could just deliver a line
and you felt like you were in on it and
they weren't i mean
it was brilliant yeah i remember quick i
love how much this podcast just devolves
into movie talkers for both [ __ ]
items
but uh i remember quick change i loved
when i first saw it
love it love that one what about as
funny as [ __ ] too oh
so funny but as a comic i'm so insecure
i gotta get a laugh every ten seconds i
gotta have punch lines out the ass and
he could just milk it and sit in it and
i loved it
and i could i think i'm kind of like in
awe of that yeah that's a good point
i mean sometimes we gotta we gotta sit
in it i mean we're both i think similar
in that way where
we both need that bam bam bam yeah
and sometimes you gotta just say now let
me
because i think we see some of the
problems you see some of those guys that
take too much time and we're like i
don't know
yes exactly but when you do it just
right
there's nothing better i mean like i
think freud would say laughter is a
release of tension
and and there's no greater release than
when you make them work for it a little
bit as an audience so like yeah i think
murray kind of mastered that
well said yeah great point what do you
think about now with like younger people
like my girlfriend is seven years
younger than me
and movies to her you know we quote
goodfellas we quote
bill murray we can quote most movies
movies had such an impact and she's like
oh i never saw this i'm like you never
saw coming to america she's like i've
never heard of it i'm like i just show i
had this old girl
coming to america yeah yeah and then you
turn to that dude you're like oh i'm
just a dude
like on that dude cliche like you need
to see this movie yes
yes i'm not like you've never seen pulp
fiction pub fiction like changed my life
changed the way i looked at things in
the world she's like i've never
seen paul i'm like oh my god
our buddy ronan hirschberg uh i was
talking to him today and he said the
funniest thing to me where he said uh
you know i'm i'm alone in this pandemic
i'm alone so i'm just watching great
movies
which yeah he's like that's that's what
you do when you're alone you're not
gonna like [ __ ] on a movie by yourself
like i'm not gonna i'm not gonna say it
i was like oh that's such a [ __ ]
great point but
you know what so he's like i'm just
watching like citizen kane and you're
like that's kind of it gets boring when
you're only watching greatness you kind
of want to watch like
something you could you want to watch
like point break every once in a while
you know
right right my point is uh you need
nachos after a fillet every now oh
of course and there's nothing better
than watching like
speed with someone i think speed is a
good movie but like yeah it doesn't
better than watching a movie like that
and just like
i mean keanu's acting in that movie like
he's gotten way better that wasn't like
pete keanu yet you know good point yeah
so it's like you could still kind of
[ __ ] on the acting a little bit
and uh i kind of i kind of
jeff daniels is in it for like five
minutes and dennis hopper is devil i
mean that movie's all over
sandra bullock is like a young starlet
that movie's great i saw that in the
theater sandra bullock
yeah dude dennis hopper is a villain so
[ __ ] funny
oh yeah what do you do what do you do
there's a wildcat behind the wheel
wildcat
uh cameron from ferris bueller's in that
he's like the annoying country i love
him i love him dude succession
yeah great actor underrated pops up
everywhere too he would like pop up on
sitcoms even when he wasn't
where he was in like scrubs dude he's
great on spin city
right he's in a great episode of
justified too he plays uh
he plays a complex character for one
episode it's great but uh
yeah dude something about those shitty
movies too
but i've definitely dated girls where
you have to be like you
i'm not an annoying guy today but
there's a couple you gotta see i'm sorry
like
i know come on what are you doing it's
like saying you never heard
this beatles song or you never heard
stairway to heaven or
uh you know like an elvis tune it it
gets weirder
of american culture goodfellas is a must
although i'll die in this hill sopranos
is [ __ ] way better dude
well it's a different animal it's a
different animal but like
when you got that type of animal like
it's like okay
it's like we're talking like a little
animal i found a way bigger animal
it's way more meat why am i going back
to that little animal
there's more meat i mean you can as
seasons as years and years of
development character and psychologist
a therapist i mean imagine you'd have a
therapist with no passion good fellows
is incredible and i always love it
i'm just saying sopranos is like my
favorite thing but i i do think like
yeah godfather is incredible godfather
is incredible like you re-watch some of
these movies
uh i mean i was with salacuse the other
day he just was like just watch the
opening of mean streets again i was like
all right fine i've seen it yeah that's
why
i'm like yeah it's pretty [ __ ] cool i
mean like you relive some of these
70s movies where they're like hey we're
gonna breathe we're not going to
never now instagram it's like i got a
headache
it's a reel i got to hit him in 30
seconds and then yeah
you look a taxi driver and you're like
all right you know i'll take it so true
it's so true but
by the way can i ask a dumb new york
question yeah again i've been drinking
uh yeah me too okay good i'm gonna be
[ __ ]
i'm gonna be gone by the end of this one
this podcast
vodka is going to do damage to me yes
say by the way i think we're we're
eight hours in here but i i've lost all
sense of time
we'll go long who gives a [ __ ] salaccus
is my guy he's your guy he knows his
[ __ ] he's the man he's a buddy if you
don't know
he directed my last special up on the
roof it's on youtube he directs a lot of
mark shorts on his youtube channel he's
our good buddies from new york he's
a great job actually got to see him
tomorrow oh nice yeah
uh i'm writing a show with the guy he's
he's a killer he's great
he's funny and he's a great dude and
he's got a
adorable new boston terrier so oh is
that right
oh yeah oh okay good for him so we have
a similar
uh sense of humor he loves like o a he
loves patrice he loves all that [ __ ]
so he he knows his stuff and he's a he's
a he's a great uh
like portal into the real world he's got
a wife a kid but he's still like an
artist so he's got like a toe and
everything but i love it it's something
i love about him he's a sensible
artist which is hard to find yes exactly
but here's my dumb question he grew up
he's older than me he grew up in
brooklyn in the 40s or whatever
and you grew up in manhattan yeah is
there a is there a new york connection
at all
or is that some [ __ ] that i made up
in my head absolutely
oh really of cour are you kidding me
yeah well yeah you never know i mean
it's
interesting it was absolutely instant
yeah i mean like even when
i mean we hit it off we hit it off
immediately i mean uh
through our mutual friend jessica pilate
who is right
was a colbert booker and produced larry
charles new netflix show and it's done a
million things but like
i'm just saying for the listeners here
but uh sure sure uh
she's next she's a she's a shark i love
her new york hustle energy
and uh yes talk about a new yorker a
real new yorker and then she introduced
manchester you'll love him he's a new
yorker it's the first thing she said i
mean
yeah man i had it eventually and then
when we were talking about the new
special the up on the roof special
he's literally to talk about new york
he's going
it's gonna look like uh like a punk
version of manhattan
like the opening of manhattan and i was
like you're talking my language now you
know like this is
this is what i want to hear that's a
great way to put it great and then
right as where does he set it he goes it
was his city and i turned him i go
and it always will be i mean that's how
we [ __ ] hit and it was like that's
how i knew he was the right guy to i
love working with him he's the best i
mean he's the
same man and the opening in manhattan
gives me chills
same you're so [ __ ] beautiful yeah no
there's an absolute new york connection
for sure by the way is that wagner
wagner no it's uh gershwin
wrong germany
yeah you know it's public domain so you
can buy it
oh it's so old when music is that old oh
yeah because we were going to use it but
it was just like what
who are we kidding yeah yeah
up on the roof everyone's like all right
come on this is going to sound racist
but hang tight every [ __ ] every every
pre i'm giving a
discretion what do you call it uh
disclaimer
sure but it's not racist but it's gonna
sound racist
as a as a white guy who grew up in a
black neighborhood you realize black
people like started everything like rock
and roll
blues you know hip-hop so
i get some kind of white hope in
classical music because i'm like thank
god
this wasn't stolen from a poor black guy
like elvis is just doing black [ __ ] you
know
oh yeah no elvis justin timberlake
they're just doing
black culture but then you hear
classical and you're like all right they
got whitey could come up with something
jesus christ i'm not saying it's
in that way i'm just saying it like i
think you're just saying one way
you want to bring stuff to the table
yeah
it's funny exactly you know like i was
watching i was watching an interview
with these
basketball players today uh jimmy butler
bam adebayo and
and tyler hero and you know the first
two guys are black and tyler is
a white guy and they're talking about
how they can't swim
and tyler hiro says i can't swim and
they're like oh all right you're one of
us
that's how they brought them in that's
great you can roll with us
i was like ah that's kind of fun i love
that [ __ ] yeah that's that's what it's
all i'm all about connecting and
everybody gets weird when you bring up
race but
i i want to kind of know i i get that
from you as like as
as road dogs we want to do every uh
every city every every market you want
to do red state blue state you want to
i mean like there's comics that want to
play to their crowds and there's comics
that want to build their cars we want to
we want to
turn people like there's that's how we
came up as comics is like
you know doing those hell gigs where
you're like let me see if i could turn
them
yes exactly and even outside of comedy i
don't want to get to a place where like
asking questions is considered
taboo or or offensive or whatever i just
want to like i want to learn i want to
get to know and the only way to get to
know is to talk and discuss
and i worry that discussion is is
like off limits almost now and i grew up
talking [ __ ] with guys in my
neighborhood i went to public school
that was all it was like what's up with
this what's up with that
you know they'd be like what's up with
nirvana and i was like what's up with uh
you know this uh public enemy or
whatever the [ __ ]
and i think that's a better way to be
but it you know we get we get dicey gets
into the dicey party
school but the same [ __ ] we had the same
conversations you know yes
here here like i think it's fascinating
like
like asses i think that's a whole black
thing
like i grew up in the 90s it was all
tits you don't like asses
no i do but it wasn't it wasn't a thing
i think black guys brought that in
it was all tits i grew up
admittedly i grew up more of a tech guy
for sure we all did
now it's like i'll say this about the
asses it's getting a little out of
control like you see some of these
instagram people and it's like
it's like this and i'm like all right
it's not supposed to be shaped
like like that that's yeah yeah it's a
little aggressive is it not
it's a bit much and i don't know if
anyone can't be healthy one of those
instagram
she just died we talked about that oh
that's right that's right
yeah so they go it's like everything you
go too far
you know peter's like hey you kill a
cockroach is like killing a a
monkey you're like well now you're going
too far you know it's the same with
asses
all right we've got all the rails here
we got the give me a newspaper story a
news story
oh geez you got it all right so i heard
this is a horrible joke and it
i feel i love it i'm embarrassed to say
it but
it was a so a news story came out about
how um
no one has had sex in space ever
ooh okay and i thought well
the people of the challenger got [ __ ]
all right i'm gonna
the pun stuff on twitter but it's clever
and it works i mean it definitely is uh
that's a good joke oh thanks yeah it's
it's it's a fun joke
that's not one you're bringing on stage
but that's a good social media that's a
good like twitter
post for sure right right uh oh well we
both had a casey anthony joke
what was oh what was yours yours is
is way smarter than mine mine was uh
very a to b
what well i mean dude's [ __ ] twitter
you know yeah
new york post let me let me read the
actual headline okay
casey anthony launches private
investigation business in
florida you can't you can't write a
better setup it's
jay leno did he hear about this
casey anthony right right so of course
you're like well florida
that's that's that's funny right there
that's funny right there yeah
the meat of it is oh i wrote uh i heard
also jaslane maxwell's opening a women's
shelter oh that's good i like that
that's really good
it's very you know you got the i saw i
saw people post like
ones that's way better yours is way
better than the oj thing i saw it
oh were people posting o.j i saw someone
post like oj
uh oj's opening a pi thing too i'm like
yeah that's two that's two
uh two the same you're the same man mine
was uh
it was a that's like if batman uh beca
that's how he became batman after he
killed his own parents that was my angle
yeah well it's all right it's whatever
it's twitter man
it's uh casey anthony man
[ __ ] you see that documentary
yeah i did actually is it crazy i heard
it's nuts it's pretty wild and
it it shows you how crazy she is she was
blowing she was blowing the lawyer right
yeah oh yeah she's [ __ ] nuts and like
kind of attractive so that
that throws a whole new wrench that's
how you get the documentary you're not
getting it if you're not a looker
i mean yeah look i mean jodi arias is
not getting all that air time if she's
just like a [ __ ] five who hacked up
her boyfriend
you know right right it's funny looks
equal tv time like airtight ted bundy
i mean is he there both ways is he that
[ __ ]
[Music]
i know he's still a murderer is he
selling a netflix special
well he got he got on netflix he did an
hour before us
yeah killing murdering is uh the key now
no he really uh that was a good one that
was one of the last i heard the one uh
something on
something beach on hbo you know what i'm
talking about
that's like oh middle beach yeah
everyone's saying that's a really good
one it's good it's really good it's a
bummer but it's good
that's the thing it's like how much of
this [ __ ] can you watch without like it
like without having an effect it's
already gray outside every day
it's already you know 40 degrees
i have to force myself to take a walk
like i'm 75.
it's true but here's the the cra first
of all that was directed
and shot by the son of the kid whose mom
got murdered so that's also like a mind
[ __ ]
unreal when somebody has the theory that
things are kind of obviously outside of
the pandemic
things are so easy now that we have to
find
sadness interesting that's that's not my
theory
i don't know if i agree with that i i i
definitely get that but i think also
uh i think also when things are dark
you gravitate toward dark because it
feels like it mirrors your reality in a
way like
i mean like when you have a breakup you
listen to breakup songs
yeah i think it's true it doesn't it
makes you feel better in a weird way so
sometimes i think if it's not too dark i
mean murder is like
extreme but it's not too dark it does
give you like some sort of like all
right
there's other people right what i'm
going through
um i think people are dark like well
it's just where we do this weird math
like if you do a pedophile joke we were
like hey that's [ __ ] up that's
horrible but then they'll be like the
michael jackson doc is out
isn't that weirder isn't that worse that
you're watching that with popcorn like
he spread his ass cheeks and macaulay
culkin and i'm like
i made a joke about a a fictional thing
you're watching the real thing i don't
know
it's a good point i i heard someone make
a great point about michael jackson is
like
it took us so long to come to terms with
the bad [ __ ] he did because we were
complicit i was like
that's true yeah yeah and you're
talented
people like it but also when you're the
one when you like hear like i got a
glove at home
am i gonna turn on them you know what i
mean like yeah it is harder when you're
part of the problem people love to be a
part of the mob but it's not as easy to
be a part of a mob when you're like oh
[ __ ] i've got those records on my
[ __ ] phone
yeah i grew up with that [ __ ] my mom
sings it you know
when remix to ignition comes on we're
all we're all fist-pumping
it's a good song it's a great tune i can
separate i can separate like okay this
guy's a monster but
he put out good art yeah i was thinking
about i was talking to my mom today
uh about roald dahl the uh oh big
anti-semite again
it originally started with my buddy ron
on again but we're talking about roald
dahl and like how
you know what an anti-semite he is and i
mean the guy had the most
imaginative mind yeah charlie and the
chocolate factory james and the giant
peach you can't imagine that jews are
people too like at that point it's like
it drives me insane
it's so true it's fascinating that
that's why racism is so
fascinating because you're like it's
like being a serial killer like how does
your mind go that way
yeah they're all people we're just
different pigment or religion or it's a
bummer when it's a childhood guy
where you're like yeah i love the twist
i love this [ __ ] growing up you know
uh i heard the guy who invented rugrats
hates uh
armenians don't don't you dare
oh do the rugrats talk about like the
best uh voices
ever yeah all the voices are gold
that's true phil i've never thought
about that tommy they're all you hear
those voices like this is these are like
a big reason for the show's success
completely because the animation was
like okay
but yeah the voices were great but
they're adorable in the animation
they're cute kids
yeah angelica was always terrifying [ __ ]
i hated her we all hated her
she was she grew up to be a real [ __ ]
you could tell she really
definitely she was a cutter and she was
promiscuous
no doubt about it tommy was like
angelica you need to get it together
we're worried about you and be like shut
up
shut up that'd be a fun show rugrats now
like now that they're like 17 or 18 yeah
that would be good
it's just dark as hell it'd be great
they just went in a real
terrible direction what i'll give you my
my uh my news
story is chrissy teigen uh what happened
new york post she's been sober four
months
which i'm like first off that's not a
long amount of time when you're
rich yeah that's when you live in a
[ __ ] 10 bedroom
i'm like all right you know yeah
alcohol is an escape you don't need to
escape when you're in a beachfront
mansion
you know what i mean i deserve a [ __ ]
medal of honor every night i don't have
like 10 of these
you know right right like she's married
to a [ __ ] handsome musician
yes it's like your life is great i
understand it's a disease i'm not trying
to trivialize an illness but like life
is good let's be right
yeah i know she did she lost a baby i
think but you know oh yeah yeah that's
true
that's true that's was it a miscarriage
i don't know actually that's i'm not
thinking about miscarriage i'm really
judging someone without knowing the
whole story i will say
that's part of the story part of the
show i think but it's part of the
it's a bit it's a bit you're not you
don't know her personally but i don't
know
personally john legend seems like a
great dude she seems all right but i'm
just saying
the way we frame the way we yes
celebrities on the back
for just generic accomplishments where
it's like
you know when they lose weight or when
they do it's like
i look i get it's a stressful job i get
what you exactly
but let's not suck them off for losing
20 pounds when they have a great
trainer all right come on yeah and don't
put that [ __ ] in our face when other
people have real problems with like
fentanyl
and addiction and all this [ __ ] it's
like these people are poor
and dealing with that and it's it's it's
a different world
and they should be more aware i guess is
my point
like also is that even news was she even
was she even uh i mean it's the post i
don't i know i mean but like people
drink i mean i think people are all [ __ ]
everyone's getting [ __ ] up these
days man like yeah yeah everybody's in
rehab and you can't blame them i mean
suicide is higher
everything's [ __ ] up now and honestly
i get messages from people and i'm sure
you do too
saying you know that they're struggling
so if you're struggling out there man
just
try to hold on i think it's gonna get
better but uh i know it's it's a
it's a tough thing but there's there's
help out there suicide hotline like
like do not try to try to hang on
because
[ __ ] man dark year but but i think
there's gonna be a light at the end of
the tunnel so
i hope i hope and yeah when the when the
cloud's clear i think
i it's like you had that great tweet
months ago
where you said isn't it amazing like
after all this that people might still
get offended at a joke
yeah and that sums it all up well i mean
it's gonna be a while but
i i think it's gonna be a while before
the i think people are gonna the first
few months i think are gonna be like the
best
of our lives i hope but
yeah i think there's going to be a
there's going to be a period after where
they go back into the comfort zone i
think as you said before like we get
we're going to be like oh we're grateful
but i think i think people fall back in
the word
who they really are right well i don't
think people realize that being upset by
a joke
is somewhat of a privilege like if you
have the time to write about it and
tweet about it and write a letter
and and yelp and cancel and all that
like
that means you got extra time you got
extra hours in your day like
you know he's not yelping his uh kids
making iphones
or you know some lady who's getting
beaten or who has to go to a farm and
and or a mill or a guy working at the
factory
they're they're not just reply to it
thanks lady not getting beaten
yeah that's uh no i i also i'll go the
other way too
your life is [ __ ] ah no one with a good
life
is yelping negative reviews no one is
like boy guess what you get a bad food
delivery you're not like
dear burrito loco how dare you
like all right guess what no one getting
their dick sucked is writing a [ __ ]
bad
trip advisor review so good point yeah
jay-z has not been on there uh so
exactly
it goes both ways right it's like
privilege but it's also like your life
is probably horrible as well
yeah so i try to remember that whenever
someone like tags me in a thing and
they're just like you're [ __ ] the
worst blah blah blah
i'm like all right but you felt the need
to tell me that rather than just move on
to the next thing so
there's some anger in here too so just
right i
it hurts you're hurting more than i am
on that yes
good way to look again good great point
so
uh what's uh do you have a joke this
week a new joke
oh yeah i got i mean i feel like we're
going long here this is this i mean but
it's a hot app though right hot app i
mean i can't tell
yeah i mean we're growing into it man
i'm having fun doing this with you
it's also good to see you because i just
like i'm used to seeing your face
at the clubs i'm used to like running
into you and we'll catch up we'll like
find a corner and just shoot the [ __ ]
and now it's like that's gone
i know i know that's such a part of
comedy that nobody talked about was like
seeing the other comics because
we're weirdos we're introverts we're
we're dark we're [ __ ] up so we like
seeing other comics because it's like
all right i'm human i'm normal this
guy's weird too
and that was a big part of it and uh
that's all gone even if you can get on
stage on a roof or a field with a heater
you still lose the hang yeah it's
different and also like
we took for granted like each other
being stuffed into booths
and just shooting the [ __ ] and getting
hammered and just
having those special nights and telling
funny stories
there's like there was like a what i
really miss is like the way
comics in new york kind of like we we
[ __ ] with each other in this like
playful way that's like so
we're so all of our friends i feel like
are good at it and i i love that because
whenever you're with someone who ball
busts you when they're bad at it and
you're like
ouch okay you know like you're like oh i
miss the
the comics who are like they they [ __ ]
on me but it's like you can feel it's
out of a place of love and
yes so that's tough too to lose
to lose that type of interaction is
is tough and some comics are so good at
that ball busting
quick witted thing that like they can't
do that right now and that's got to be
killing like phil hanley
is one of the quickest like he's still
[ __ ] on me i'm talking
okay great good cause that's like a
skill he has i'm like i don't want you
to not have that or not
be able to exercise that because you're
still good at it yeah
now dude he's he's so good at that [ __ ]
yeah yeah i mean he had a line in your
special that was like a great
sidewalk line i mean dude glad this was
documented
gold i love that when i told myself my
my
biological dad lives in artist housing
but he's not an artist and phil goes
well he is an escape artist
it's like classic he's got that kind
it's almost like the british type of
ball buster yes
like it's almost like the butler in
arthur or something
where you're like oh [ __ ] it's like
snooty and
you kind of like bam at the same time i
love that type of humor though i like it
he's so good at that so good and like
maybe it's canadian maybe it's a
canadian thing because they're they're
more british than we are
more european true yeah it's like arthur
wasn't it like i haven't taken my bath
it goes how i left the media
whatever the line is i'm sure i
butchered it but it was something like
that no that's it i'll alert the media
it's so good
so quick all right i'll try it i'll try
an idea
or something please uh this this could
be a one-liner but i'm i'm missing
something so
my girl wants to get pregnant she wants
to have a kid wow
i love when you break news to me through
bed
this is my post but
she's i'm not saying we're having a kid
i'm just saying like she's
letting me know if she wants a kid but
don't you love me we're talking i'm like
so i had a breakup and you're just like
did you
that's how we communicate sometimes it's
like that great regan bit where
his buddy gets divorced it was like a
20-year marriage against divorce he goes
golfing with this guy and he comes home
and the wife's like
what do you say about the divorce he's
like oh it never came up it's
like dude's hanging out they don't talk
about that [ __ ]
uh he's a legend and a great guy and a
great guy
great guy great guy great comic legend
the whole thing
so she wants to have a baby eventually
but she's
she's still young and she's like i'm so
vain
that i'm worried about getting pregnant
and ruining my body
so i might maybe we should get a
surrogate and i was like yeah yeah i'll
just [ __ ] her
but that's that's a little too harsh and
too quick of a turn i think for the
public
because i'm like wait what so i'm just
saying like the giant no
that doesn't hit did you try it yet i've
tried it but i'm like
i'm saying [ __ ] so i'm like maybe i'm
getting a laugh on that
but i don't know if the audience is
totally grasping what i'm saying
so i got a circuit to [ __ ] is such a
funny idea to me not just
for the for her body but like it'd be
funny the funny thing is she's having a
baby still but i'll [ __ ] the surrogate
who's still hot
yeah ah i don't know i think i think
it's i think it's good i think it's
funny already
okay okay i'll just [ __ ] her you're like
i like that you're looking at it as a
[ __ ] as a w
that you're just like you're just like
yeah i get to [ __ ] a different person
like that's how long you've been in a
relationship
she's like we've been together a long
time it's time we have a baby you're
like yeah we've been together a long
time i would love
to [ __ ] a different person right okay i
didn't know if it was clear
i got it i don't know if a crowd because
i think i will say this i think the
surrogate thing is like
i think it's rare is the thing right
right like you hear it amongst obviously
the wealthy
and a lot of celebrities do it i think
but uh
yeah i mean i know it just i've heard of
it but i yeah i don't know i don't know
if it's common knowledge
okay okay that's that's good uh but i
think it's
i think it's a bit i think it's funny as
long as people get it i think it's funny
all right i was
i felt like every once in a while when
you have a funny enough bit i'm like who
gives a [ __ ] i mean like yeah yeah the
right people get in the wrong people
will be like oh i should have known that
that's true but you know it's like we
said earlier we want to hit every group
every
person is it
is it wrong to explain it in the setup
which is like when you it might slow it
down yeah maybe
maybe that's not bad maybe i can't tell
you
which what is that it's like well that's
when you bring in a third party and
you're like oh
exactly i'll [ __ ] her ah
that might be a better way to do it and
it explains it a little it's like kind
of like two birds one stone there
all right that helps there's something
there i had something about uh you ever
watched chopped
yeah do you like do you like that [ __ ] i
know i love chopped i've seen a
million hours of chopping i love that
dude to roan sanchez
oh yeah he's got the gang tattoos on his
arm
yeah my angle is like every i can't get
this to hit right but it's something
here
like every every gang every chef used to
be in a gang for some reason where
they're just
well you're like what what [ __ ]
tortured past they're always like uh
yeah he's i heard him say
cooking saved me from going down a dark
path and my angle is like
what [ __ ] gang just let you leave to
pursue the culinary arts
uh you're like is there something like
there's only one way out of the bloods
and they're like what do i have to
murder someone they're like no you have
to perfect this meringue
right here if you crush it if you crunch
a french tart we'll let you walk
uh yeah i need a good example but
there's something to that i think
that's a great angle there's something
maybe to the the knives
like they both have knives gangs and
cooks
you know it's all about the knife like
and maybe when a body
is they gotta get rid of a body he's
like cutting it up
you know yeah like uh like they do it
like it's a like it's an onion like
chit-chat
yeah exactly they're chopping it like
ginsu
they're like oh here's sanchez and he
opens up his coat and it's like all
these great knives like all the silver
knives
you know also the uh the mess they're
good at getting rid of a mess
yes yes exactly and they can use
everything that's that's the whole thing
in chop is like you got to have a
[ __ ] kumquat salmon
you know pepperchinos and whatever like
they can make something out of this
body you know they're like they're like
cookie macgyver i can't i like it
it's right right mindless show it's a
salad
it's a good time love that show i love
all that
so funnies and again that's so true
about chefs it's like tattoos and
checkered past
they're badasses yeah i think it's a lot
of thing too
is a lot of times too is uh these
restaurants are like some of the last
places where they don't do like hardcore
criminal record
background search oh that's funny i
think that's one
it's like weirdly one of the last
because you think about it you're like
oh dishwashers i think they're like
that's probably a job you get if you
have a
checkered past right but then you think
about you're like all right well they're
in the kitchen
at that point it's like you may as well
just like who gives a [ __ ] at that point
right
right right it could also be a bit and
this might be a stretch but
the gang they lose him he goes off to be
a chef
i love the idea because my douchebag
friends did this in high school
where they would come into the
restaurant and like [ __ ]
you know piss off the waitress and get
shit-faced i like the idea of a gang
being like sanchez is working at uh
you know bubba gump and they all go like
you know terrorize the place
you get free drinks he's a crypt i'm a
crypt you know did you underage drink
like crazy and new i mean you must have
been an animal
in new orleans dude it was great we knew
everything what's that
fake id no we didn't need them back then
like you could just go to a place and
you had the one friend who had armpit
hair
and like a little cheese stash and he
could buy we were 14 he's buying [ __ ] at
a bodega
the 5'3 guy with side burns down to here
and you're like that's his [ __ ]
that's his talent he can he can go first
yeah exactly he's like give me the
cigarettes and they let that slide he's
like all right [ __ ] it give me the the
hooch
this is a hot one man we're [ __ ]
we're rolling with this
oh yeah now i i don't wanna i don't
wanna leave you now it's like
now i'm gonna be back in a hotel room
with a flight in the morning
yeah is your girl still there no she
left today
because uh they added a sunday show so
she was like oh i didn't know
so she just left did you oh did you
change your flight
yeah i had to change my flights tomorrow
because we had a sunday that's great
though
it's great i mean people are dying to
come out but yeah uh
i just hate getting back to new york on
a monday it's like a pet peeve
oh the traffic well just i i like to
start the week
in my bed you know i hate the idea of
like the week starts it's a mental thing
i hear you somebody with the traffic on
a monday too especially
yeah yeah okay [ __ ] kill me i know
sunday when you wake up sunday go to the
airport it's nice it's like your little
day
you're right you kind of there's
something about starting the week right
you feel like this is
job as some stability yeah yeah
i even thought about getting like a
midnight flight out
like on sunday night and just landing in
new york at three hours
i love i love a late flight like that
because you're like i wake up in bed
i don't have that and also you're on and
like what are you gonna do you're either
gonna
you're just gonna watch a show or read
something on the flight you it's like
that you're [ __ ] home it's great
what's it it's like when you're in a a
bum a [ __ ] bum town and your friend your
opener's like should we drive back it's
we're not gonna get home until four a.m
i'm like
drive back [ __ ] it always let's go back
always
always i to me i mean i don't really
draw i mean
i'm worthless dude i don't drive i'm
talking to sally so i'm seeing tomorrow
he's like i'm biking i'm like i guess i
gotta like walk down to like 17th street
right now it's like it is i'm worthless
i can't ride up i tried to ride a bike
down the highway i
wiped out like three times i got like
cuts all over my arms yeah i'm terrible
what
yeah oh man i could teach you how to
drive if you ever want to
i am i'm a good teacher i i feel like i
can maybe that'll be an episode
oh yeah i like comics doing
daily things we'll figure that out yeah
i would love that
you can draw i mean if you can play
basketball you can drive i got a license
oh you do but i i sweet talk my way into
it i didn't deserve it that's the most
new yorker thing ever
but i sweet i failed too and and i got
her and i was self-deprecating out of
the gate and she laughed i was like i'm
in
uh i said i said i've already failed
twice you can't fail me
i'm gonna i'm gonna look terrible and
she laughed i was like all right i'm in
and i and i was not good and she passed
me i didn't deserve it
i love the idea of you running over a
kid and they're like how'd you get a
license you're like i sweet talked her
that woman's gonna go to jail there's a
kid who can't walk right but i can uh
you know
i could still land a joke so
we should we should tell people like you
know what what do we need for this
we got to get a network at some point
right or do we go independent with this
what are we doing
i think we need a we need a decent logo
we're willing to put on itunes and just
have as a logo for our show
and someone to help with that if someone
wants to help with that hit us up
yeah please somebody sent us a great
theme song i already lost it was a dm
and i
it's already been buried we have a good
theme song okay so we're going with that
i i mean i like would you let me should
we play it one more time i like it too
but i didn't
i never hear it let's let's uh let's go
with it
let's see one more drink i don't know if
i could find it i was
actually singing that in the shower day
it's catchy it's a catchy tune so you
will get here i'll play horn
ready
one more round one more round
all right soul it's great i think it's
great
that's my boy colin smith singing there
wow he sounds so different
he's the most versatile [ __ ] musician
he's incredible yeah that's
i think that's a song i mean all right
great i mean speak if you're against it
we can get them do something else but i
think i think we got to use that but uh
i love it i mean if someone out there
wants to put that the animation or
something
yeah for a nice intro for this we'll
we'll pay
so let us know and uh and if you want to
help us with lips and
all that [ __ ] we're too lazy for
that so someone help us with that
and uh yeah just do that well we got to
get the
to get on itunes we got to get a a thing
you know
oh oh like a what do you call it a
network or uh yeah i don't know i'm
worthless but i know we got to get on
something like that so
yeah help us with that and uh
thanks for listening and we're going to
keep them coming so you keep uh you keep
listening we'll keep banging these out
hell yeah buddy always a pleasure great
app it's going to be hard to top this
one next week
we will we'll top it yeah
i'm i'm half in the bag i'm gonna rub
one out to a lobster tube
[Laughter]
me too okay all right man
take it easy take it easy